solving equation means now I wonder what
would you put into this by the way I
wonder if I've given you enough so by
the way here are some clues for you
these are these are equations I can
solve right how would you how would you
would like what are you trying to do if
I say to you so say this okay so I'm
going to do this now we're all gonna get
to do in a second okay just push me why
would we do this what's the point of
doing this and the answer is what we
trying to do is we're trying to find
values right specifically this letter is
primitive there we don't know what's
equal to but if we shift things around
we can find its name so sorry vision
means fine values for them what did we
say they were called again
this is the language of algebra right
and then this part it's a bit close but
we're looking for values that will make
the equation true now the way we get
there as you'll see in a second is we
want to make it as easy as possible to
simplify things that's part of why our
basic rules of mystery okay but just
politically we're saying is we want to
find values that make equation work or
in he's the technical almost almost easy
whoever looking for is satisfied so I
would evaluate why did sales to change
the way that satisfy the equation right
so you will see as we get to this answer
in a second what is the next value like
what's the next line dollar all right
1010 right okay now why is 10
significant to this it satisfies it this
is trying to get something looks like if
I put 10 in there it works it's true
it's valid or if you put a other number
in figure okay so therefore the way we
go through it is by all of these kinds
of things we've seen before you might
have to expand some brackets you might
have to collect some like terms but
that's where you're trying to get to
that's the last square on the board okay
so this is a simple equation have a look
at this one it's early a little bit more
complicated what could we do to both
sides that would get us something
simpler then got line there any
suggestions so you have to get x using
move the one okay so I can get this one
over here the way I'm gonna articulate
that is I'm gonna add one to both sides
yeah I'm gonna so in fact you can even
put a plus one plus one the reason why
that's helpful is consistent equations
about balance right it's two things that
are exactly the same so you gotta do
something one side you better do it to
the other right okay so I get that right
I can now again just like ID key I want
to do something to both sides I'm gonna
divide by this number right again no
matter nay what's it cold
the number at the further / such a state
coefficient coefficient nailed it right
so if I divide by the coefficient
it'll comes out so I just get let me see
on the left and on the rise and thank
you okay again lost for the work they
see all right doing here right is which
Friday corner this printer won't get him
on his own in a dark alley and then beat
him to a pulp right now we did two steps
yeah two steps we added one we divided
by three does it matter which one
you first but I have done it the other
way around
try it
remember and I'm making you could put
this on the right-hand side with me
we'll do this in parallel right
first we added one then we divide by
three let's just see what happens if we
do the other way okay this is the first
one I started here in black I'm gonna
divide by three of them so I get this
well because remember like what we say
we trying to get this trying to quarter
the C on his own right and this does
sure enough get rid of that three that's
a touch with the coefficient right in
fact I'll get C take away plus yes
because it's one and then what's 2003
yes I think that six and six point blue
curving six yeah six point six can i
what would I do from here yeah good I'm
not gonna have one anymore am I cuz I
divide everything by three very valid
point which would you prefer I prefer
the first one right that's why we
thought of it why did it make sense why
was it more efficiently and when one
infraction is I can't we avoided
fractions right so you can see as many
repository this but peak one that's
smart up all right one that's quick up